[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute starten wir ein schmexperiment und
möchte heute drei Pancakes Rezepte
machen und zwar die drei besten Pancakes
Rezepte also drei wir werden heute
American Pancakes machen wir werden
japanische so vielfältig machen und dann
werden wir noch paar Fotos zubereiten
das sind holländische Pancakes das wird
lecker und ich hoffe es klappt doch
alles so wie ich mir das vorstelle wir
starten jetzt mal mit den American
Pancakes also die schöne luftige
fluffigen amerikanischen Pfannkuchen
wir nehmen dafür zwei Eiweiß eine Prise
Salz zwei Esslöffel Zucker zwei Eigelb
einen Esslöffel Zucker Vanilleextrakt
200 g Mehl plus Backpulver und die nimmt
mein backmehl und 200 ml Milch also ich
nehme immer gerne das backmehl weil
alles was mit Backpulver zubereitet wird
mit Mehl und Backpulver könnt ihr immer
das backmehl nehmen das ist extra fein
es ist extra fluffy ihr müsst es nicht
sieben ihr müsst nicht durchmischen und
ihr habt immer die perfekte Menge an
Backpulver mit dabei deswegen nehme ich
das ganz gerne zuerst nehme ich jetzt
mein eiweiß mit Salz und das wird jetzt
kurz steif geschlagen
und dann lasse ich da den Zucker
einrieseln und schlagt das ganze steif
aber nicht ganz steif so bisschen so
halbsteif so bisschen schloss sich muss
es sein ja also nicht zu trockenrühren
[Musik]
okay in der zweiten Schüssel verrühre
ich jetzt das Eigelb mit einem Esslöffel
Zucker und Vanilleextrakt
und dann einfach schön cremig rühren und
ihr könnt natürlich wenn ihr eine
größere Menge zubereitet auch alles mit
der Küchenmaschine machen aber ich zeige
euch heute alle drei Rezepte ohne
Küchenmaschine denn nicht jeder hat eine
Küchenmaschine aber jeder will die
perfekten Pancakes
[Musik]
sieht perfekt aus guck dir diese Masse
an
so weiß cremig solange solltet ihr das
auch richtig schön rühren bis das Eigelb
weiß cremig ist
für den Rest brauche ich keine andere
Gerät mehr
so gut aus
dann nehme ich jetzt hier abwechselnd
mehl mit Backpulver
immer so eine kleine Portion hebt es
unter dann kommt ein Schluck Milch dazu
und dann einfach immer nach und nach
alles schön unterheben
und ganz am Ende kommt dann der Eischnee
damit das ganze schön luftig wird
[Musik]
ich erhitze jetzt gerade auch schon mal
meine beschichtete Pfanne mit etwas
backtrennspray auf mittlerer Hitze
vorsichtig Eischnee unterheben am besten
auch so ein zwei bis drei Portionen Gott
die Pfanne ist jetzt schon heiß jetzt
nehme ich einen Eisportionierer die
normale Größe wie auch bei Muffins und
gebe jetzt hier immer einen
Eisportionierer voll in die Pfanne ihr
könnt auch die eckige Gusseisenpfanne
nehmen
da braucht ihr nur ein bisschen mehr Öl
das geht auch gut kann man gleich
mehrere gleichzeitig auspacken
[Musik]
und sobald hier die Oberfläche fest ist
könnt ihr die Pancakes vorsichtig wenden
und fertig backen und es dauert bis hier
ungefähr vier Minuten
[Musik]
jetzt sind die American Pancakes fertig
und ich habe jetzt in Pancakes
Spezialisten extra eingeflogen von zu
Hause denn Ella Özcan ist die
pancakespezialistin überhaupt gell ja
jetzt darfst du mal probieren okay
womit ist du denn deine Pancakes am
aller allerliebsten
[Musik]
Puderzucker drauf geben
Puderzucker ich mach dir so einen
schönen Teller guck mal isst du auch
gerne ein bisschen Früchte
packen wir die hier so mit drauf ne
weißt du noch als ich die ganze Zeit auf
die Idee geklettert bin und dann
von der blauwitze ja
und in Amerika da ist man die Pancakes
am liebsten mit so einem Sirup mit so
einem Ahornsirup magst du den auch
drüber oder lieber Schokocreme
haben
uns gedacht dass wir einfach mal die
besten Pancakes Rezepte zubereiten und
das ist nur die Nutella Creme die kannst
du ja gleich noch dazu essen
sollen wir erstmal den Pancake an sich
probieren und Du darfst dann ganz
ehrlich sagen wie sie schmecken
mit Blaubeere
eine kleine
und
[Musik]
wie viel Punkte
ja
yes
dann darfst du hier den Teller voll
Nutella Pancakes mitnehmen und ich mache
tschüss
und wir testen gleich das zweite Rezept
nämlich Soufflés
für diese Pancakes nehme ich zwei Eiweiß
eine Prise Salz 25 Gramm Zucker 2 Eigelb
etwas Vanilleextrakt 35 Gramm Mehl plus
Backpulver oder nimmt das backmehl und
25 Gramm Milch von den Zutaten
herunterscheidet sich zu den American
Pancakes weil einfach die Eier und
Zuckermenge fast identisch ist aber die
Mehl und Milchmenge unterschiedlich denn
es sind also Pancakes und höre ei-anteil
und dadurch sollen sie etwas fluffiger
luftiger sein wir probieren aber wir
starten eigentlich direkt fast gleich
nämlich eiweiß und Salz steif schlagen
Zucker dazu und dann nur halbe verrühren
[Musik]
mit Vanilleextrakt wieder cremig rühren
also auch wieder das gleiche nur ist da
jetzt nicht noch mal Zucker mit dabei
die Pfanne erhitzt sich auch schon mal
[Musik]
dann rühre ich jetzt hier das Mehl mit
dem Backpulver und die Milch ein einfach
nur ganz kurz
[Musik]
dann hebe ich den Eischnee unter
und jetzt sollte die Pfanne gleich auch
schon warm sein damit der souffleteig
nicht rumsteht das war sofort mit dem
Backen loslegen können
[Musik]
gleich zwei Methoden bei denen ist
nämlich so wenn ihr zu viel Teig in die
Pfanne gibt dann fallen sie gerne mal
zusammen weil sie eigenes Gewicht nicht
halten können ihr könnt da vorbeugen
indem ihr Weinstein Backpulver nehmt
oder eben cream auf Tatar also einfach
Weinstein ich habe jetzt tatsächlich
noch bisschen Weinstein da und hebt das
kurz unter
sollte man im Idealfall mit der Mehl
unterheben ansonsten zeige ich euch aber
gleich diese zwei Zubereitungsmethode
damit es trotzdem funktioniert dafür
nehme ich jetzt den XXL Eisportionierer
also noch mal eine Stufe größer ihr
könnt aber auch den normal großen nehmen
und wir brauchen gleich ein bisschen
Wasserdampf in der Pfanne also auch hier
fetten mittlere Stufe
jetzt ein Eisportionierer voll
und dann gleich den Deckel drauf geben
für den Wasserdampf
erstmal so ein bisschen anbacken
und ich gebe noch einen Schluck Wasser
dazu für mehr Wasserdampf
nicht zu viel
jetzt ein paar Minuten ausbacken und
wenn die Oberfläche anfängt fest zu
werden gebe ich noch mal Eisportionierer
voll mit obendrauf ich versuche gleich
noch eine Methode und zwar mit dem
Backring mit einem Burger Ring
wenn man so richtig perfekt haben will
daraus aber ich will das ein bisschen
höher ist also packe ich jetzt noch eine
Portion drauf
richtig richtig fluffy
und ich mache das jetzt in zwei Personen
sonst wird der groß und nicht hoch
normal
machen wollt dann zeige ich euch noch
was ich habe jetzt hier den Backring
also einen Burger Ring ein Backpapier
Streifen
den lege ich da rein
falls er nicht hält einfach mit einer
Metallklammer fixieren hier oben
wir wollen nämlich den perfekten
japanischen soufflé-
und sobald ihr seht also ein Glas Deckel
ist immer ganz gut sobald ihr seht dass
die Oberfläche fest ist wenden wir ihn
langsam
[Musik]
richtig vorsichtig denn der ist so
fluffy
oh der ist schwarz oh nein
[Musik]
und da kann ich jetzt direkt
zwei portioniere voll reingehen
[Musik]
anfängerfehler
ist schon mal etwas so richtig perfekt
machen will und dann so richtig fehlt
[Musik]
al
lustig sehr gut aus
sieht gut aus
nicht verbrennen deswegen habe ich hier
die
ich bin gespannt
okay ich glaube
japanesecake es funktioniert ja doch wo
wir allein schon mal das hier
oh mein Gott eine essbare Wolke oh mein
Gott ist es lecker ah da packe ich das
auch noch so bitte
so ist einfacher aber so ist glaube ich
schon
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier noch eine
Stäbchenprobe gemacht einfach hier
seitlich rein gestochen damit ich auch
sehe ob die Mitte da ist
jetzt kommt der ultimative
Geschmackstest hier sieht so lecker aus
Japan Experten
gegessen
[Applaus]
was ist los
Leute
ich probiere jetzt mal okay
it's a pancake it's a welcome übertreib
doch jetzt gerade oder es ist eine Wolke
in deinem Mund
ja schmeckt gut
setze geht im Mund wie so eine Wolke
also so stelle ich mir eine Wolke vor
aber ich habe gerade das Ei
rausgeschminkt aber ja
ich cool das ist in Ordnung ich weiß gar
nicht wie ich ihn schöner finde ich
glaube der ist schöner also natürlich
aber das größte Japan auf der Welt mich
wahrscheinlich du immer ehrlich
wow aber
zugegebenermaßen American Pancakes sind
einfacher zu machen und schneller das
ist halt so ein Gericht des zelebriert
man halt wie toller
so viel jetzt
machen ich habe innerhalb von fünf
Minuten
okay
Pancakes Check auf jeden Fall zehn von
zehn zehn und jetzt kommen meine
lieblings aber ich habe noch nie
Profession selbst zubereitet denn ich
hatte bisher keine Puffer des Panne bis
heute morgen Murat anna hat mir der Papa
ist gerade geschenkt aber ich zeige euch
natürlich auch die Zubereitung ohne die
Pop hat jetzt haben wir zu allererst in
Efteling gegessen im Freizeitpark in
Holland die gibt's aber mittlerweile
auch im Europapark sind so richtig
kleine süße tolle Pancakes aus einem
Hefeteig und die werden dann mit butter
und Puderzucker gegessen
alles klar
übrigens keinen Deckel habt der hoch
genug ist damit der so Flip Pancake
nicht nach oben backt nehmt ihr einfach
eine hitzebeständige Schüssel und stimmt
die über so wie ich jetzt hier meine
Schlüssel denn dann klebt auf jeden Fall
nicht
[Musik]
verwende ich 7 Gramm frische Hefe eine
Teelöffel Zucker 20 g Wasser 250 g Mehl
da ist jetzt in 550er Mehl einen halben
Teelöffel Salz 300 g Milch ein Ei und
etwas Vanilleextrakt die Zubereitung ist
ganz einfach ihr nehmt Hefe Wasser und
Zucker und verrührt alles in einer
Rührschüssel falls ihr Trockenhefe
verwendet einfach die doppelte Menge
ihr könnt den Teig aber auch ganz gut
zubereiten und im Kühlschrank
aufbewahren über Nacht denn dann kann er
schön aufgehen und dann könnt ihr am
nächsten Morgen Puffer des Backen wobei
die Holländer gar nicht zum Frühstück
sondern eher als Nachmittag Snack Essen
habe ich gelernt
Wasser rein
kurz verrühren
und hier Salz mit Mehl
ich gebe jetzt mal die Hälfte rein
Ei und Vanilleextrakt
[Musik]
keine Klümpchen entstehen
und jetzt gebt ihr immer mal wieder
Milch und Mehl dazu und rührt den Teig
schön Klümpchen frei
wenn ihr Buchweizenmehl habt dann könnt
ihr auch gerne da die Hälfte des
Weizenmehls durch Buchweizenmehl
ersetzen denn das machen die Holländer
auch ganz gerne gell
mache ich hier den Rand schön sauber
denn dann kann ich auch ablesen wie viel
Teig ich habe
500 ml der Teig wird abgedeckt und dann
lasse ihn eine Stunde ruhen oder wie
gesagt im Kühlschrank über Nacht wenn es
über Nacht macht würde es aber würde ich
die Hefe Menge auf jeden Fall reduzieren
oder ihr packt das ganze in den Backofen
bei gerstufe 34 Grad im Dampfbackofen da
braucht nur eine halbe Stunde und am
Ende sollten so richtig schöne
Blubberbläschen entstehen so sieht der
Teig jetzt aus ich zeige euch das mal
guck mal ganz viele schöne Luftbläschen
er sieht so perfekt
aus den fülle ich mir jetzt in der
Dosierflasche ein
damit ich es gleich etwas einfacher habe
beim portionieren
gut ich habe jetzt hier meine Puffer des
Pfanne die Diana mir geschenkt hat die
habe ich jetzt auch schon eingebrannt
ist nämlich aus Gusseisen ich meine wenn
jetzt keine zu Hause habt nehmt ihr
einfach eine beschichtete Pfanne oder
die große Gusseisenpfanne schön heiß
werden lassen
ja ja
nie auf siebeneinhalb
und ich meine ich habe dir auch schon
mal gewendet in Efteling damals schnell
gehen weil dort war so eine riesen
Platte wir probieren ich will sie jetzt
bis zur Linie und warte bis die
Unterseite dann gebräunt ist schätze ich
jetzt mal
crazy
ten dann können wir versuchen ich nehme
einfach so ein Dreizack sondern Gabe
nehmen und dann war das einfach so und
so
und habt ihr die Technik gesehen einfach
so weißt du machen die meisten rum mit
den Stäbchen dabei geht es so zack
[Musik]
die sehen ja schon echt perfekt aus aber
ich finde da fehlt so ein bisschen die
goldene Farbe deswegen mache ich die
zweite Portion einfach mit Butterschmalz
vielleicht backt es dann besser
okay jetzt wie im Park
[Musik]
wenn ihr den Teig in der Dosierflasche
lasst dann solltet ihr nicht so viel
einfüllen weil der geht ja noch auf
und dann kann es passieren dass er
ausläuft also füllt den am besten erst
ein wenn ihr ihn verwendet den Hefeteig
lebt wie wir alle wissen und das war
jetzt für euch quasi nur zum zeigen dass
man so nicht macht
das sich selbstständig
krank Mädels
probieren wir mal
hi hattet ihr die im Europapark auch
probiert ja tatsächlich nein also
die Butter ist noch ein bisschen zu kalt
aber und jetzt hier so dick Puderzucker
drauf
und jetzt nehmt euch am besten so ein
Stück Butter
nicht die schmilzt ja so ein bisschen
dann richtig
fettiges mit Puderzucker
vielleicht nicht das ganze Butterstück
leicht Hefe
und dann die Butter und der Puderzucker
das Kombi
wow ich glaube die gibt es jetzt öfter
das immer dabei
ich glaube Emre wir brauchen eine Puffer
des Banner
das mit meinem gleich sagen ich glaube
da drin kann man so coole andere Sachen
machen
dann raus Teig rein Kugel drauf oh mein
Gott
die drei Pancakes Rezepte bzw ein
amerikanische Pancake ein japancake und
die poffer hat jetzt perfekt probiert
die Rezepte gerne mal aus und schreibt
mir was euer Favorit ist unbedingt ich
finde die der Hammer
die dürfte mitnehmen ich pack den Rest
noch aus und dann machen wir ab sofort
danke also alle Rezepte gibt und falls
es weitere trendrezepte gibt die ich mal
ausprobieren soll für euch dann schreibt
mir einfach tschüss
tschüss
[Musik]
ja